So let us first review
the steady state
behavior of Markov chains.
Consider again the
following example.
This chain has some recurrent
states, some transient states,
and a single recurrent class.
So for example,
state 9 is recurrent.
State 3 is recurrent.
State 5 is recurrent.
And why are they recurrent?
Because whenever you are in
9, no matter where you go,
there's always a
way to come back.
You can go to 3 and come
back, go 5 and come back.
And actually, this
is a recurrent class.
And this is a recurrent
class, because all
these recurrent states
communicate between each other.
What about the other states--
well they are not recurrent.
So for example, state 1--
and once you are here,
there is a possibility
that you go there,
and you will never come back.
So it can not be recurrent.
So it's transient.
What about 4?
4 also has the possibility
at one point to go there.
And then from there, it
will never come back.
So 4 is also transient.
As for 2, no matter
where it goes, well,
it's going to reach or
touch a transient state.
So by definition, it
will be also transient.
So they have three
transient states
and three recurrent states.
Also, this recurrent
class is not periodic.
So it's aperiodic.
And why is it not periodic?
Well, here, there is
a simple way to tell.
We have the existence of a
self-transition probability.
And that's enough to show that
this recurrent class is not
periodic.
So this is one of the
nicest possible Markov
chains in the sense that they
have the following property--
the probability that
you find yourself
at some particular state j.
At time n, when n
is very large, it
converges to a
steady-state value
that we denote by pi of j.
There are two aspects
to this property.
First, the limit exists, so
the probability of state j
does not fluctuate.
It settles to something
in the long run.
And furthermore,
that probability
is not affected by i.
Now, if we don't know where
the chain started, and we
want to know the unconditional
probability of being in state j
in the long run,
when n is large,
then either we are given
an initial distribution
over the states,
or we can choose
any initial distribution.
For example, we can assume that
all initial states are equally
likely-- or any other
type of distributions.
And then you can condition
over all the initial states,
use the total
probability theorem,
and you're going to get the same
answer, pi of j, in the limit.
Let's see how to do that.
So this is the
summation of all i.
So you condition
on that state i.
So it's Rij of n times
the initial probability
distribution of your choosing.
So this is the total
probability theorem.
Now, in the limits,
when n goes to infinity,
this goes to pi of
j, independent of i.
So you can take this
expression, the limit,
and take it out
of the summation.
And then you have the summation
of-- probability of x0
equals 1.
These are probabilities,
so they sum to 1.
So in the end, you have
that converges to pi of j.
So the conditional probability,
given the initial state,
is in the limit, the same as
the unconditional probability
when n is large.
And in that sense, it tells
us that x of n and x of 0
are approximately independent.
They become independent in the
limit as n goes to infinity.
So if the Markov chain
has run for a long time,
and you are asked the question,
"Where is the chain now,"
then your answer should
be, I don't know.
It's random.
But it's going to
be in a particular j
with that particular
probability, pi of j.
So in that sense, the
steady-state probabilities
are valuable information.
So how do we compute them?
Well, for transient states,
like these, they are 0.
So pi of 1 is 0.
Pi of 2 is 0.
And pi of 4 is 0.
And why is that?
Well, if your initial state
were one of the states here,
the probability of being in
here is 0, no matter what.
But even if you
started here initially,
in one of these states,
you might, for a while,
fluctuate and turn
around like that.
But eventually, after a
finite amount of time,
you will go to that class
and never come back to 1.
So in the long run,
the probability
of finding yourself
in state 1 will be 0.
And this is the
same for 2 and 4.
Now, how do we calculate these?
Well, for these states
in the recurrent class,
we compute them by solving a
linear system of equations,
which are called the
balance equation-- these--
together with an
extra condition.
The normalization
equation here has
to be satisfied, because
these are probabilities,
and they have to sum up to 1.
And we have seen that the
system of m plus 1 equation
provides a unique solution
to this kind of system
for the recurrent class.
So you would apply that
to that recurrent class.
And in that example,
you have three states,
so you would choose m
equals 3 for that example.
And you would solve the
system to get the pi j.
Now, what if we had
multiple recurrent classes?
Consider this chain.
It is an expanded version
of the previous one
with additional states.
Some of these are recurrent,
and one is transient.
But now we have two
recurrent classes.
And that was our 1
class, so class 1.
And now we have a second
recurrent class, class 2.
So what happens in
the long run, when
you have situations like that?
Well, in the long run,
if you start from here,
you're going stay here.
And in some sense, the study
of that recurrent class
is the same as the study
of that recurrent class.
And in order to find the
steady-state probabilities
of these states, assuming that
you started in one of these,
will be exactly
the same as before.
So you will use the same
system, with m equals 3 here.
Now, if you had
started here instead,
again, this is a
recurrent class,
and you have m
equals 2 states here.
And in order to find what is
the steady-state probabilities
of these two states, you could
use the same kind of result
here, but you apply it with
m equals 2 in isolation.
So you just concentrate on that.
If, on the other hand, your
Markov chain started from here,
for example, for that
specific example,
you're guaranteed that the next
transition you'll end up here.
And then you can do the
same thing as before.
We still know that the
steady-state probability of 8
will be 0 and 0 and 0 and 0.
Now, what would happen
if you started from here,
from one of these states?
Well again, for a
while, you might
travel throughout
this system here.
But eventually, you're going
to move away from that.
And you will either go
through a transition going
into that recurrent
class via this transition
or via this transition.
And once you're in there,
essentially, the chain
will remain there.
And so you do the same
calculation as before.
And if, on the other hand, you
transition away from that class
and arrived in this
recurrent class,
then you would apply the
result that you had here.
So in some sense, conditional
on the fact that you left
the states and you
arrived there--
in that conditional world, you
can isolate yourself and really
solve the problem for
that class-- and the same
from that class.
Now, of course, this raises the
question, if I start from here,
how do I know whether I'm
going to get here or here?
Well, we don't know.
It's random.
So we will be interested in
calculating the probabilities
that eventually you end
up here versus here.
And this is
something that we are
going to do towards the
end of today's lecture.